my first up chief a former Democratic
National Committee Chair whose new book
is hacks the inside story of the
break-ins and breakdowns that put Donald
Trump in the White House Donna Brazile
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so glad you feel free enough here on
HBO to call me that I just called him a
bad [ __ ] I've been waiting to
use that word on television for what 15
years absolutely and there's a couple of
it right I appreciate that
well I'm your fan - I fact I feel I saw
you took a lot of crap for this book and
I thought wow I have so much in common
with you because I think we both do the
same thing we want our side to win right
so we criticize it when necessary and
some people don't like any criticism
that's correct but we're doing it it's
not like criticizing the Republicans
that's a different kind of criticism
love it stuff get your [ __ ] together
right I may need a win right Tuesday was
a great day by the way it was a way I've
heard you say this before but it's so
true we cannot just compete and in the
so-called blue states we have to compete
in all 50 states we won in Georgia that
was tremendous a Liberian mayor and I'm
going to Montana now I gotta check that
out oh you know I mean that is just I
played I play these cities as economic
you know when you're in the cities it's
always great it's always great it's
about city and country that's right it's
really not about the state itself when
it you know we had a great turnout on
Tuesday in Virginia alone the minority
turnout increased by five percent yeah
33 percent of all voters were people of
color that is if we continue this trend
next year we're gonna see a blue wave
all across America
so so why is the Democratic approval
like the lowest in a generation it's
very low correct but why do you think
that both political parties are
underwater simply because I think the
American people are tired of Washington
DC they're tired of failed policies they
really would like to see both parties
get something done our numbers are far
better than the Republicans the
Republicans are as popular as a root
canal
but wait I sort of lumped both parties
there under the rubric of failed
policies
I would think Washington is not work and
the American people believe liberties
have failed not Obamacare no it's not a
failure and I think that people are
pissed off with the Democrats because
they a lot of that I think disagreed was
coming from Democrats themselves so
we're saying we don't stand up for our
stuff correct that I mean I heard Trump
say over and over and over these last
month's yeah that Obamacare is a failure
it's a message a disaster it's a
disgrace and I don't hear Democrats
full-throated Lee saying that's just
plainly not true it's not an in fact
Obama care enrollees spiked spiked
lately because they were afraid it's
going to go away and an open enrollment
by the way continues throughout the next
couple of weeks you saw would happen to
me whether voters there supported
policies to expand Medicaid to over
eighty nine thousand people now I don't
know what the governor will sign that
bill because he I mean that that that
ballot initiative but people upset
across the country they upset at
Democrats and Republicans our approval
rating ratings are a little bit better
our generic Balaton for next year is far
greater than the Republicans but they
want Democrats to deliver on more than
just talking points they want the
Democratic Party as you mentioned to
stand up the fight for these policies to
fight for Obamacare I think you're going
to see a new Democratic Party emerge in
2000 but stunned by it okay
I gotta push back a little bit on but I
feel like here a little bit buying into
their narrative of a pox on both their
houses and it's just failed Washington
and then people don't have to look
specifically into the issues and what
they stand for I mean their policies
have failed trickle-down economics is a
failure right okay they just passed that
that banking bill that said people can't
get together in class-action suits to
sue banks that's correct
no Democrat voted for it I know Steve
Bannon who pretends to be a populist
wanted this but what we are there people
out there in America going please take
away our right to sue the banks I mean
you've heard Elizabeth Warren you've
heard Chuck Schumer I mean Democrats
Chris Murphy they all went to the floor
they all went out across the country
just like when the Republicans tried to
repeal and replace Obamacare I think
you're hearing the Democratic Party make
a bunch of noise unfortunately bill when
you have the bully pulpit when the
Republicans control most stage houses
across the country often voters don't
hear exactly what we stand for but it's
coming through and I think they'll hear
more of it next year okay that's just a
big year 360 days get ready yeah no and
it was a very encouraging week
absolutely
first of all I feel like we spent all of
2017 still stuck in 2016
I agree can we put the Bernie Hillary
sing aside that Great Divide I mean
that's what all the controversy was with
your book you know that the elections
were the primaries were rigged and you
know it doesn't matter first of all now
it's over and also the policy
differences between the Bernie folks and
the Hillary folks were really small to
begin with that's another thing that
could hold us back well you know Bill
after a presidential campaign we should
assess what happened the Republicans did
an autopsy report
I assume that the Clinton campaign would
do their form of autopsy but as chair of
the Democratic Party I felt a
responsibility to tell my story I was
chair I became chair because the party
was hacked your surgery was hacked and
so this notion that somehow another I
cannot tell my story the story of the
Democratic National Committee in a year
that Donald Trump won
by less than a hundred thousand votes
the party needs to examine that and then
I believe we can heal you cannot heal an
open womb by just dressing it you know
dressing it you have to analyze it talk
about it all of it and then I think we
can move forward okay so you I thought
the most surprising thing I read in the
book was when you said after Hilary's
shocking collapse which I did not see as
a shocking collapse she had pneumonia
right right stumbled on the curb
I mean how grueling a campaign is I'm
surprised they don't do it once a week
I've been involved in a lot of campaigns
21 I have a lot of campaigns under my
belt but I was worried about Hillary but
you said you were thought sort of
replacing her at that I didn't know it
was in your power first of all to
replace her magical powers I can tie
your hair back to the call it was 10
years ago I've got magical powers you
know things and make it a little bit up
you talk about great hair I might lend
you some of this stuff I have not
Hillary Hillary Clinton when that video
went viral I began to receive calls from
not just the media but people within the
Democratic Party and as chair of the
party the convention rules as well as
our Charter says the chair shall confer
width now I kept my own counsel and the
next day I had someone from the Clinton
campaign with me to dampen these rumors
but yes I had to keep my counsel about
what would happen if Hillary didn't get
up if she wasn't able to recover and get
back on the road she did I went back on
TV I tapped those rumors now and God
knows I wanted Hillary to run all the
way to the White House because that was
my intentions when I became chair to
party okay
well we need you the party needs you
your country needs you
thank you for being here thank you for
write nice book and keep at it you go
girl
[Applause]